[Music]  you know I tried might try my best and I  really felt a very strong sense of  obligation responsibility to to get it  right Ben Affleck making his first  public appearance since he and Jennifer  Garner filed for divorce at the odd fest  international film festival over the  weekend ladies and gentlemen and a slit  Oh Ben was on hand to accept an award  for his portrayal of a man with autism  in the accountant hopefully it's made me  more I mean compassionate empathetic  more thoughtful about you know what  really might be I'm just under the  surface of the next person that I meet  you'll hear the theater at the mall or  on the bus or wherever it might be that  you know people are capable of so much  more than we initially give them credit  for and and in some cases capable of  really astonishing inspiring things  you  [Music]